talking about the beginning of life
there and how we
sort of come into this world i want to
talk about the end
for better or worse life is short
how can we add a sense of urgency to it
well i i would say by reminding yourself
that life is short that's
that's that'll add a sense of urgency by
noticing
you know i calculated i don't know my
parents are
when my parents were in their 70s 60s
perhaps
i i usually saw them about once every
two years we communicate a lot more than
that but we live a long ways apart
so i calculated you know well my dad's
probably going to live till his mid 80s
or late
you know somewhere in there and he's six
he's 70 let's say i'm going to see him
40 more times
it's like okay 40 more times
that's urgent so you better get it right
because you don't have it you don't have
that many opportunities
you know it's the same when you're
formulating relationships in your
adolescence late adolescence in early
adulthood
you don't have that many experiments to
run
you know and you get you get old a lot
faster than you think
so attempt attention
attention attention is
an under rated um faculty it's not the
same as thinking
it's watching to see what's there in
front of your eyes
and and to guide yourself as a
consequence of what you perceive
it's the it's the faculty that
transforms thought if you let it
so and your conscience alerts you as
well
tick tick tick you know you're wasting
time
and very few people are happy with that
some are burdened by it more than others
but virtually no one
escapes that voice of conscience
i suppose to some degree that's that's
the willingness not to
engage in self-deception chapter 3 and
beyond order is about that
people don't really repress the things
they don't want to face they just fail
to unpack them
you know like maybe you're on youtube
regularly and every time you shut the
computer off you feel somewhat disgusted
but you don't pay any attention to that
for a while for two years but then you
decide you're going to pay attention
then you find out well the reason you're
disgusted is because you're wasting your
life and you know it
and that disgust is indicating that but
unless you attend to the disgust and
unpack it
let it reveal itself as informative you
don't know what the message is you just
have a
sense of disquiet it's not easy to
transform that sense
of disquiet into an actionable plan and
often you have to talk to someone about
it as well
you have to discover so it's not like
you're repressing the emotion exactly
it's that you don't
undergo the difficult process necessary
to unpack it
it's effortful it comes back to that
assessing assumptions
that we said before if the goal of life
is to live a life which in retrospect we
are glad that we lived
it's important to give ourselves
perspective to develop that
metacognizance to step
away from the urgent to step away from
the phenomenological
day-to-day existence because the present
self is a petulant child
it's lazy and it wants the path of least
resistance and that glass of wine and
that new movie on netflix and the couch
looks really comfortable
very rarely does it yeah well that's the
danger with impulsive happiness
is that it does have that present bound
quality
and in retrospect that can lead to a
life that's not well lived
generally that yes yes yes
life definitely places philosophical
demands on you
whether you wanted to or not and so it
is useful to step back
i mean that's likely why the trade
openness
evolved that's the creativity dimension
that's the dimension that
that allows people to engage in
philosophical discourse and
to think laterally and it it does allow
you to
step back and look at things on a
broader scale
and to generate creative alternatives
the problem with examining your
assumptions is it's
very disquieting you know because
you want things to act the way you
predict and desire them to act and
you work within a set of axioms and you
act them out in order to maintain that
predictability that desirable
predictability
if you mess around the more fundamental
the axiom that you question
the more uncertainty you release
and some of that can be positive but a
plenty of it can be anxiety provoking i
mean just imagine that you're in a
relationship and
you know it's it's maybe a year into it
you haven't formalized and finalized it
but then
one day you allow yourself to ask the
question is this the relationship i want
to be in
well that's a fundamental question but
just imagine now you're destabilizing
your entire future
you're destabilizing your present you're
destabilizing your past
because while engaging in the
relationship you're acting out the
assumption that it's the proper
relationship but now you question that
that means
the story you told yourself about what
was happening while it happened
even though it's already happened was
wrong and
something else had happened and then you
have to think through what actually
happened so
it's unbelievably demanding and the more
axiomatic the assumption the more
certainty is cast into into troublesome
chaos
now you could say yeah but
the alternative is worse and i believe
that
often that's true but but the thing
about the alternative is that you can
always
forestall it right that question
tomorrow
you bet you bet and it's a very powerful
temptation and no wonder
you know do you want to dig up the body
now or do you want to wait a month it's
like well it'll be more rotten in a
month but
but it's not a month it's not now right
it's not now
and so i i understand why people don't
want to delve into things even if their
emotions indicate that they should
i mean i would see this all the time if
you're trying to settle an important
issue with your partner let's say
that can be a tremendously troublesome
excavation process and there's no
shortage of pain
but if you sort it out
then maybe things can be better it
doesn't mean it's easy or
or or uh or pleasant quite the contrary
it's like surgery it's not it's like
surgery to remove something
you know that shouldn't be there it's
necessary but
man still surgery
i think it's possible to develop a
cathartic emotion
towards that i think it's possible to
down regulate the level of discomfort
that you feel when you do assess your
assumptions
on this show a lot of the time i try and
present uncomfortable truths
so insights that are accurate
but disquieting to learn and that to me
gradually exposing people and myself to
more and more of these and learning that
it's not an
existential threat it's not going to
destroy my ego
or learning or learning that it is an
existential threat but that you
can handle it correct which is really
what people learn in
exposure therapy that's effective is the
thing they're afraid of
is frightening but they're tougher than
they think
and so and and that's very useful to
learn it
and yes i i do believe well it's also
the case that
if you decide that you're going to delve
into trouble as it rises
you're likely not to avoid the delving
process
more than necessary so the thing won't
grow into a monster that's quite so
large
you know and so once the relationship
you have with your
intimate partner is reasonably well
constituted
and you decide that you're going to
address problems as they arise
then it's less burdensome than
the total reconfiguration that might be
necessary before any of that has
has been has been started it's like
meant it's a form of mental hygiene i
would say in some sense
and so and you do get better at that
with practice
and um
you you perhaps you also get less likely
to jump to the worst
possible negative conclusion you know so
so and that's also useful you don't
catastrophize so
so much thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy
peace